hello my name is arun optay i'm the ceo
ceo of cloud limbs and today's talk is
about
qaqc testing in your in-house cannabis
extraction lab
so what we have found is we've been
getting a number of customers
who are cannabis extraction labs and
what they're doing
is instead of just sending out all of
their samples to third-party analytical
testing labs
they're setting up in-house testing labs
in order to be able to get
real-time results to optimize their
extraction process
so i want to talk about in this talk i'm
going to be covering
all of the reasons why a cannabis
extraction lab
would want to do their in-house testing
and then the benefits that a lims
gives to those testing labs in order to
be able
to optimize all of their processes
particularly using trend analysis
so first let's go over a little bit of
background of what is a cannabis
extraction process
the cannabis extraction process has five
main steps
the first step is collecting and milling
this is basically
taking your beginning product which i'll
just generically call cannabis because
it could be hemp but that's just
cannabis with a low thc
and grinding it down to the optimal
particle size
for the extraction process there's all
kinds of
equipment available from this i've seen
high-end
instruments which are professional
milling machines with automatic loading
apparatus
and hoppers and these are for very large
production facilities
to small production facilities where it
might be
a technician using a vitamix like i've
got in my on my kitchen counter
from costco to grind the cannabis down
to a smaller particle size
the second step is the extraction
process itself
the extraction process can use a number
of different solvents
there's butane there's co2 which i'm a
big fan of that's been increasing in
popularity
after the extraction process then and
this could actually be done either
before
after extraction there's activation and
decarboxylation
so the reason for decarboxylation is
the active ingredient the active
cannabinoid
in cannabis is thca
but thca is not actually psychoactive
so traditionally back in the day before
legalization when people used to smoke
cannabis
the actual smoking process the heat from
that process
would cause the thca to convert to thc
this is the decarboxylation that's
caused by
a slow heating process
then we introduced vape pens the vape
pens had
the same advantage because since they
were heated they self-decarboxylate
but once edibles topicals
and tinctures came on the market then
the extraction labs that were making
these products
need to do the decarboxylation step
themselves if you skip the deep
carboxylation then the end product has
thca which is not psychoactive
the fourth step is winterization as is
implied in the
the term winter comes because it's done
at low temperature
and it's basically a precipitation
of unwanted lipids from
the extracted product there's a whole
bunch of lipids
which you do this precipitation step to
remove
if you don't do the winterization step
what happens is and this
it can be skipped depending on what the
final consumption method will be
but if you're putting it into a vape pen
those lipids will actually leave a
residue
that burns so you'll end up with very
unhappy consumers
who load your product into their
vehicles
and end up with a black burnt gunk at
the end
and have to continuously clean their
pets so the winterization process
removes all these unwanted
lipids in edible products it's kind of a
matter of opinion whether you want to
remove them or not
it depends basically whether you want
the flavor
of the cannabis to be to remain or you
only want the flavor of the edible
so i've seen products chocolates for
example some of which
have had the winterization step done
which tastes just like the chocolate you
can't actually take it to cannabis
and other products which have not had
the winterization and then they taste
like cannabis
so it really depends on the end product
you're going for
the fifth step is the third-party
testing although i would argue that
before you do that third-party testing
and in fact at each step through the
process
you should be doing in-house testing so
the in-house testing you'd want to be
doing
when you first receive the product
before milling because that's how you
ensure
that the grower is providing you with
a consistent starting material
that is to the specs so for example if
you
paid for a certain thc percentage you
want to ensure that the product that
is delivered with representative
sampling
is at that thc level and not just from
one little part of the bash
but throughout the whole batch and you
want to do it for every batch that's
delivered
because there's high variability from
growers and what they can produce
for you so once you know what you have
to start with
then you can do the extraction step
after the extraction step you want to do
another in-house
decarboxylation you can do real-time
testing to see
when the process is complete and after
winterization before sending out
by testing at each one of these steps
or after each one of these steps you're
able to optimize
using gmp your entire process so that
your end products
have reproducible cannabinoid
interpreting profiles
and you're able to optimize the amount
of time
taken for each batch step so you can run
as many batches as possible
with your existing set of instruments
now let's talk a little bit about the
forms of cannabis extracts
there's crumble batter butter shatter
distillate
crystalline dry sift rosin and bubble
hash
most of these forms the crumble batter
shatter crystalline dry sift rosin and
bubble hash
are end products that can be sold
directly to consumers
and are usually used in vape pens they
can be added for smoking
distillate is generally then used as an
ingredient
to make some other product it could be
something as simple as a vape cartridge
or it could be something more involved
like turning it into a tincture
or turning it into an edible so as we
were discussing before with the
decarboxylation step
decarboxylation is necessary for the
distillate for any application except
for the vape pen application
what are the methods of consuming
extracts well there's
edibles capsules tinctures vaping
dabbing and topicals
for all of these edible versions which
would be the edibles the capsules
the tinctures and the topicals none of
which
involve a heating process for those who
would do the decarboxylation
for vaping and dabbing it wouldn't be
necessary
so now i want to go on to the first
reason why a cannabis extraction lab
would want to set up an in-house testing
facility
so one of our customers who came to us
because they actually encountered a
problem
is a colorado-based cbd product
manufacturer
so they receive hemp they do a cbd
extraction
then they actually make a cbd topical
uh product they do use a pretty
basic workflow co2 extraction followed
by decarboxylation
then purification chirping enrichment
for the particular
terpenes that they're advertising for
which in this case is for pain relief
and then uh quality control which
previously they had been doing
only by sending out to a third party
testing lab
and that's when they encountered the
problem the problem
was test failure so they went through
this whole
expensive process starting with a fairly
large batch and they were getting a high
failure rate
we checked in with the state which
actually publishes this data and found
that in a given
time period 20 of the products the
extraction products
were failing in uh the third party
testing
so this represents a huge financial loss
for the extraction companies
which then either had to destroy the
product or put them back for
re-extraction which is very expensive
and leads to
lower yields so with failure rates this
high
you want to do everything you can to
minimize the failure rates which is
exactly what this cbd extractor did
if your final product is rejected
by the third-party testing lab at the
end
you have big costs associated with it
you have to either do a re-extraction or
throw away your product
you have a delay in the product delivery
so that if you had dispensaries
who were waiting for your product they
are going to be very unhappy customers
and you have the resulting loss of
customers and revenues
now this is if it fails even if your
product
passes the test you still have many
disadvantages
by only doing the uh third-party testing
the first one is time delays if you were
having
tests done for different aspects
of the extraction process say you want
the initial product to be tested to
ensure
that the potency that you're paying for
is the potency you're actually getting
that if you have if you have an organic
product and it should be pesticide free
that it actually is pesticide free if
you send that out to a third-party
testing lab
on average depending on your state and
the backlog
it can take several days so this will
slow down your whole process right you
have to actually
store all the materials while you ate
the test results
if you start the extraction then you may
end up needing to throw away those
materials if you find
that the uh product delivered to you was
not the product you had paid for
there's a higher cost for all of these
tests lab backlog
is basically another form of time delay
this is that
you are operating based upon the queue
that is in that third-party testing lab
and there are crunch times
so for example when oregon first did
recreationally
legalize cannabis during their rollout
the state
they had a very bad rollout but their
state the state only approved
two recreational testing labs in the
entire state
so naturally there was a tremendous
backlog
and the extractors were stuck because it
would take
months for them with only two labs in
the state to get the third party
approval
and then they had that 20 chance of a
rejection
so you're at the mercy of the third
party lab if you only rely on thirty
party labs for your testing and finally
the gmp intermediate step testing when
we're going over the extraction process
and we talked about the five steps
you want to do your own intermediate
test through each of those five steps
the uh gmp intermediate testing steps
and for this you need an in-house
testing lab
so benefit number one for setting up
your own
in-house testing lab is you save all of
this re-extraction costs
and you get your results faster now
let's go on to the second reason why you
would want
an in-house testing lab and that is
formulation
so we are now in a huge
increasingly sophisticated consumer
market
so i like to use the analogy of wine
if you walk into the supermarket you
won't just see
a bottle of wine for sale that's labeled
wine
it will say this is a red wine that is
done with this type of grape
from this particular region of the world
by this
winery it has these fruity undertones
and other things
you walk into a high-end cannabis
dispensary now
you will see very very similar product
offerings
cannabis has become a premium product or
at least at the upper end of the market
which you want to distinguish and the
way you distinguish it is with your
formulation
you say whatever it is you're looking
for if you are looking for
a product that is good for sleep we have
a formulation an
optimization of the cannabinoids and the
terpenes
that are good for sleep if you are
looking for something that is
stimulating and uplifting we have
something for that
on the medical side if you are looking
for anti-anxiety
there are specific formulations for that
now how does an extraction lab
create these formulations they do it
through
in-house testing so for your formulation
you want to set the dosage the dosage is
the dosage both of the thc which is
generally called potency
but it's also the whole cannabinoid
profile
some of the cannabinoids are better for
particular
medicinal effects than others you
also need to ensure your label accuracy
if you are advertising
we have created this particular
formulation for anti-anxiety
you want to ensure that your cannabinoid
interpreting profile supports that
a lot of cannabis companies are now
going organic
so they source organically grown uh
hemp or cannabis and then they create a
product
but you need to make sure that your
claim is validated by
testing the product received in your
extraction lab
for those pesticides and the easiest
fastest way to do that is with in-house
testing
and finally uh adverse patient reactions
heavy metals pesticides are all
mycotoxins there's all kinds
of problems that can be associated with
patient health and all of those will
bring liability
to the manufacturer if you are not
testing properly to ensure
that your product doesn't have any of
those
now i want to talk specifically about a
terpene
my favorite terpene linalool linalool is
a terpene
that's found naturally occurring in
lavender it's produced in rosemary and
it just
smells great if i smell a cannabis
product i can detect the linoleum
it has anti-anxiety properties it leads
to mental
alertness in animal models it's been
shown to be
highly effective as an antidepressant so
when i go to a dispensary
generally a good dispensary i will say
which of your products
are high in linalool and from a good
concentration manufacturer i can
actually see
the profile of terpenes and cannabinoids
and what their formulation is for that
particular product
so if you want to create a
brand of extract that targets specific
conditions and is at the high end of the
market you need to be very careful with
your formulation
which brings us to the second benefit by
having in-house testing
you are able to control the
complete cannabinoid profile of your
final product
you can optimize a cannabinoid profile
you can get consistent dosage and
formulation
you can control for the onset of action
because depending on
what is in the final product it has
different absorption rates
you get metabolic predictability and
improves safety and effectiveness
so we've now gone over two benefits to
having an in-house testing lab
the first one being so that you don't
fail
uh in your third party testing the
second being so that you can do
formulation and reformulation
in-house to create a wide range of
products each one of which
has a specific targeted formulation
the third reason gmp
good manufacturing practices all
cannabis extraction labs
should be following gmp it's done in the
pharmaceutical industry
it's done in the food production
industry and cannabis
is very similar whether you're growing
or extracting
do it the right way how do you follow
gmp
in the cannabis industry well it starts
with your sops
you need to have an sop for each step of
your manufacturing process
this includes the extraction side as
well as the testing side
you want your sops to be optimized and
you want all of your people to be
trained and to follow them
prompt and accurate documentation of the
work for compliance and traceability
every single sample that you run needs
to be traceable back to a qc
sample a spike a duplicate a blank
whatever it is that's part of 17.25
compliance on the third party and local
testing side
it's part of gmp compliance on the
extraction side
you need to maintain your facility and
all your equipment this means
calibration and maintenance as for the
schedule
and it gets even more complicated as we
go in later because a lot of the
equipment
complicated instruments such as lcms
will have multiple sub-components each
one of which
has their own schedule for calibration
and maintenance
and finally define develop and prove the
job competency this is the training of
your staff
all of your staff need to be trained for
each thing they're going to be doing in
the lab both on the testing side
and the extraction side so this brings
us
to our third and final benefit for
setting up your own in-house testing lab
which is you can get higher yields
because using trend analysis you can
optimize the amount of time you spend
in the extraction process in the
decarboxylation process and in the
winterization process
you get better product consistency by
controlling at
each step that you're getting the same
potency the same cannabinoid profile
your final end product will also be
consistent and reduce liability since
you're able to test
right from the beginning for heavy
metals pesticides mycotoxins etc
so benefits of an in-house testing lab
the benefits
are at each step of your process in your
extraction
step right from the beginning before you
start the extraction you're able to test
the true potency of the flower which has
been given to you by the grower
you're able to look at your extraction
efficiency
which is average efficiencies can be as
low as
30 percent so anything you can do to
increase that efficiency
will make your product far more cost
competitive
so you're able to determine your
extraction efficiency and keep working
on improving it
you can get the potency of your crude
oil right after it comes out of the
extraction before the next step
so you can see at which step in your
process are you losing your thc are you
losing your product
so that you can keep optimizing for that
post-processing the main post-processing
step is the decarboxylation
you want to determine in real time
because it's quite variable
when to stop the decarboxylation process
to do that
you need to measure how much of the
product is decarboxylated in real time
and that can only be done with an
in-house testing lab you can't there's
no time to send it out to a third-party
lab
and finally the formulation this is not
the formulation that we were discussing
before which is creating new products
this is once you have a formula with
every batch
you want that batch to consistently
follow your formulation
if there is a variability in the product
given to you to start with
they have a slightly different
cannabinoid profile slightly different
potency
you can adjust for that in the
extraction process
so that your end product meets your
formulation
even though there was variability with
your starting product or
something may have gone wrong in one of
the steps of your extraction process
to do that you need an in-house testing
lab that will tell you as you do it
oh look after this step we had a lower
potency than we expected
so now in the following step we're gonna
have to use higher concentrations
in order to bring the potency back up so
it helps you with your final formulation
keeping it consistent so i hope by now
i've convinced you that in your cannabis
extraction lab
it's very important to have an in-house
testing lab because that's the only way
you're going to be able to
avoid third-party testing do your
formulation
and follow gmp so now let's talk about
limbs and how a limbs will help you with
all of that
the limbs can help you in a whole bunch
of ways it can ensure the quality of the
cannabis sample
so basically there is a whole sop for
how you should be preparing
the sample or any type of test you're
going to do for it
those sops are all contained within the
limbs it does the tracking of the
maintenance and calibration of the
testing equipment
as well as the extraction equipment
it helps you with the documentation the
record keeping
for all the laboratory personnel and
finally
we went through the list of the gmp
requirements it helps you follow all of
the gmp requirements
equipment instrumentation instrument
calibration and
maintenance you've got a lot of
instruments you have instruments for
calibration
you have instruments for your testing
both sets of equipment
need to be calibrated and maintained
here we can see an agilent hplc
this agilent hplc has a calibration date
which is in december a next calibration
date
in september and five days before
the next calibration date the looms will
automatically
send a reminder an email reminder as
well as
in-app letting the lab manager know that
the instrument needs to be calibrated
in addition to that and this is the
added layer of comp of complexity
this instrument has three sub components
which you can see listed on the right
every one of those sub components has
its own calibration and maintenance
schedule
so if you were doing this manually you
would have
a booklet of instrument calibration
with no alerts so it's much better to do
this in the limbs so that you're
actually getting alerts
and you know ahead of time when an
instrument needs to be calibrated and
maintained so you have plenty of time to
call a technician in
testing calibration methods so you now
have your instruments tested and
calibrated
but in order to recalibrate them when
the neck
when the alarm goes off you need to have
an sop for how your test and calibration
method should be done
these are generally provided to you by
the instrument manufacturer
the challenge is because this is a new
industry
the instrument manufacturers keep
updating
the test calibration and sops associated
with any instrument
when they issue you a new one you need
to ensure
that every technician gets retrained on
it
and only the latest calibration and
testing
sop comes up so the limbs will do all
that for you
you can see here that uh we had a
particular version and then we replaced
that version with the latest version
the lims will only have the latest
version comes up so that when the tech
transition comes in
to do the calibration the technician is
following the latest calibration method
associated instruments testing the
quality of results
this is about the traceability so this
is absolutely essential for 17.025
compliance in a third-party testing lab
but it is useful in an in-house testing
lab
what it means is that if there is
liability
if there is a question well how do we
know
that the instrument that the test result
that you gave was done on an
instrument that was properly maintained
and calibrated
not today but at the time the test was
done
so you need an association between the
calibration
date and the date on which the test was
done
the limbs will track all of that the
limbs will say here you can see with our
traceability
that the particular test was done on
such and such date
here was the previous calibration here
was the sop that was followed for that
calibration
so you have a completely traceable
record showing that your instrument was
calibrated and maintained
manage documents with limbs this is all
of your sops
so the second thing that would come up
in that same liability question
is when the test was done was the
correct sop followed
this will show it to you only the latest
sop was available
and the sop that was used for any
particular test distract
this is useful in the case of a recall
of a test method
the instrument manufacturers this
doesn't happen often but they can say
there was something wrong with the sop
we issued
and the test results need to be
invalidated instead of needing to
invalidate
all of your tests with the limbs it'll
tell you
only these tests were done using this
sop
so these are the only tests we need to
redo
manage staff and training you have a
whole bunch of staff and they all need
to be trained
for each step of your extraction process
and
each step of your testing process so
here you can see two different training
courses
ion exchange chromatography and paper
chromatography
and in the ion exchange chromatography
we had five students
some did well some not so well so these
are made up names but with our made up
list of names
maxim gilbert uh he did well sonya
fernandez she did well
christina paul not so well tim yan not
so well
they were not found to be competent so
the results of this
training course are then reflected in
the drop down
when you go to assign staff to conduct a
test
in the drop down only the names of those
staff who've been found to be competent
for that particular test would appear
so that way as part of 17025 and part of
gmp
you can say well my extraction is only
being done
by laboratory technicians who are found
to be competent
and properly trained for that particular
process
quality control samples so we touched on
briefly before
anytime you do a test you need to have
traceability
back to a qc sample a blank a duplicate
so you need to be able to show i ran 10
samples then i ran a qc
sample so we know that the result is
accurate because the result for that qc
sample was accurate
and finally trend analysis this is where
i think that a lens has
the maximum benefit for an extraction
lab
you are able to keep all of your data
for all of the tests and this is
especially useful
if you've been doing those uh in process
steps so that you know the initial
product you know
what was your potency after doing the
initial extraction
you know the decarboxylation time and
you know what was your potency after
your winterization step
so with trend analysis you were able to
track the variability
at each stage from batch to batch
and hopefully over time you will make
the variability from batch keep
decreasing
so it is less and less and less by doing
this you can optimize for two things
you can optimize for your yield so that
let's say you're running an extraction
you can run an extraction forever and
you'll keep getting
more and more of the product out but
it's a diminishing return
so at some point it is it is
if greater benefit for you to stop the
process
to throw away that starting material and
put in a new batch and start your second
batch
you'll only know what that time is by
doing trend analysis
with trend analysis you get to optimize
the timing for your entire extraction
process
so this is where a limbs and an in-house
testing lab
are extremely important which is for the
optimization of your entire process
with trend analysis you can optimize the
time for decarboxylation
for winterization and for extraction
trend analysis you get the optimization
extraction process you can visualize
your gmp
you can ensure that you're getting a
consistent cbd and terpene profile
and it provides you with a detailed
overview of the performance
of your laboratory enabling you to
compare your yields to other extraction
labs
so that the lab manager can then take
corrective actions
so using a limbs gives you more accurate
results
greater productivity a higher quality
and more consistent product
and lower cost since you've been able to
optimize your yields
as well as throughput and finally you
have a happy extraction lab
you have a reduction in compliance
failures you have higher throughput and
higher yields
you have a wide product range since
you're able to create new formulations
using your in-house testing lab
and you have a reputation for
consistency of the final product among
customers
so i hope that this has been useful to
you and that you've
learned the reasons why extraction labs
in my opinion
should all have in-house testing and how
a limbs can help you
thank you very much